any assemblance of iota of support
that i had in middle school for being on
a children's show uh was completely out
the window by the time we were 14 and
15. my friends were having sex at that
point
and i was like yeah but i'm on a show
hosted by an animated dog so hello and
welcome to the roast of your teenage
self podcast
i am your host your roast coming
queen a girl who was always
panicked at the disco elise morales
and with us today we have such a funny
friend and comedian she's a stand-up and
writer you've seen her work on
reductress vulture the onion
all the different places but before all
of that
she was a graduate of new bedford high
school
it's taylor garen hello everyone
beautiful historic new bedford
massachusetts went to the public well
there were actually two public schools
and um i went to the shittier one so
okay i love to talk about this is
something that i love
to talk about which is the reputation of
different
high schools in a
suburban area or high school was
was it the shittier one in the sense
like in what way was it considered the
shittier one
okay so this requires like greater
context and that is that i went to i was
born and raised in massachusetts
um which has some of the best schools in
the united states
um and unfortunately i lived in a city
that had one of the war schools in
massachusetts
um we were poor and there are a lot of
immigrants and people of color which is
not
super normal for massachusetts and so
they were just like give them
do it do what you can you know we didn't
have like uh
the best schools um but there was a
vocational school and there was like
just the
regular public high school and i went to
the regular public high school which was
arguably worse because they were both of
equal quality in terms of education but
one
taught a trade so you could learn how to
do something
what flavor of high school was your high
school
okay so we definitely we had like
your typical kind of uh american high
school tropes like there was a
cheerleader i believe is a picture of me
uh in my cheerleading uniform i know i
was going to say not only was there a
cheerleader
we have one here on the podcast
absolutely
look at it yeah there we go that's the
truth
look at me down there with my little bow
um
yeah i was a cheerleader my freshman
year both semesters
uh we went to competitions and we lost
all the time
um because all the other bigger high
schools that had more money had people
who had been in like gymnastics for so
long who could do like backflips and
[ __ ] we were like
like a ragtag group of kids that they
found this poor town
we were i'm not getting doing like
somersaults like they gave us awards
because they like felt bad for us like
it was
really it was kind of pathetic the
picture of you like
you're alone in your little cheer
ensemble
so this is actually not a cheer ensemble
this was at um
a pep rally i did have a lot of school
spirit
um but this was i was in my cheerleading
t-shirt but this was actually
uh our pep rally right before our uh
every thanksgiving we had a big like
bonfire at the local park and we had to
make
each class would make a like a float
that they would and we had like a big
competition and we'd like ride on the
float to the park which was up the
street it was very
it was very sweet i'm loving the hair of
the boy
next to you thank you that's mark he's
still my very close friend
okay
uh makes an appearance yeah it's a
beautiful thing so
were you like i mean you're a
cheerleader so obviously
professionally you're being
school-spirited but were
you like into the events the pep rallies
the football games all of that
stuff i will say that i was only a
cheerleader for a year and it was
because
uh when we were practicing right before
competition
i got thrown up into the air and simply
forgotten about
um and i fell and i fractured my wrist
in several places
um and i didn't know until after i'd
already competed on it in
tear streaming it was simply it was the
drama
which i loved um and so i went to the
doctor after competition after we lost
that competition uh yet again
and i had a cast on for a little while
for no reason for no reason i had a
broken wrist now
um and let's say that killed my school
spirit
a bit um because school spirit literally
cost me uh the structural integrity of
my left wrist
but i did i got it back i loved
um kind of school spirity things and
it's because
i was i didn't
smoke or drink or date and so i had to
find something to throw my identity into
and it happened to be like clubs and
school stuff
and trying to distract myself from what
it turned out was just like an
existential
uh kind of dread that i felt but i
didn't i couldn't identify it at the
time that
i feel like that is a um a common
refrain in like as far as
the podcast goes it's like well i was
deeply deeply troubled by the world
around
me and so i joined a lot of clubs
yeah i literally i was like um president
of the international club
i was elected to the student advisory
council or the sap
we love to make that i also did the
morning announcements everyone
[ __ ] hated me i was the worst now
that i'm thinking a lot i was like not
fun
so you were the announcements girl
did you did you try to make them fun or
i did and it was every single okay my
school day started at 7 25 a.m which was
way too early
but every morning i'd have to get there
10 minutes early so i could go to the
office read what the announcements were
and then announce them over the intercom
and every single day i said
good morning new bedford high school and
at one point i ran for class secretary
and one of my very well-intentioned
friends
went from home home room to home room
being like vote for my friend taylor
um you know her she's the one who does
the morning announcements and everyone
was like i'm
absolutely not voting for her now wakes
me up at 7 25 in the morning absolutely
not
i lost not kidding i lost that secretary
race
to the weed dealer at my high school
actually this guy helps us yeah uh this
girl annoys us this guy drives a hot
pink
uh honda pilot with magenta flames off
the side of the side that he inherited
when his sister went to college and
sells wheat out of it
well here's what i'm gonna say is even
if you weren't the annoying
morning announcements girl that's hard
to beat
that's a hard guy to beat because number
one
as a drug dealer we know that he's
handling money yeah i
know that he is running a business
actually
and so ultimately he is qualified
and he's got a cool car so that's just
really hard
and you know he's interacting with like
kind of people of all
ages uh demographics like colors creeds
uh backgrounds uh grades in school so
really he's he was a man of the people
we are also still friends all of these
people are still in my hometown and i'm
still good at friends with all of them
well you know i mean retroactively i do
feel that we have to support his
campaign not that you wouldn't have made
a great treasurer
i thinking about the morning
announcements were such an
interesting aspect of school
did you have to say that were you the
the person who said the pledge as well
yeah it was only on mondays that we did
the pledge and i said it on mondays and
then i had to play from a very shitty
kind of janky old tape player uh
the national anthem and i didn't know i
just held a little microphone up to it
and anthem yeah we did we loved we loved
america there we also loved um
taking the uh recently pregnant teenage
girls from our local catholic school
because they sent them to our school too
today's episode of the roast of your
teenage self podcast
is brought to you by magic spoon
magic spoon is delicious i i don't
really i don't really know
what else what else to say about it
i you know it's it's a it's it's a tasty
treat
that i love to eat and that's a rhyme
that i just made out of
the love that is in my heart for magic
spoon
growing up cereal was one of the best
parts of being a kid but i had to give
it up because i realized that it was
full of sugar and junk that you really
shouldn't eat
i've personally been trying to cut down
on carbs and sugar and unhealthy
foods i'm getting married next year etc
etc and i realized that i basically
can't eat anything
anymore except for
magic spoon magic spoon has zero grams
of sugar 11 grams of protein and only
three
net grams of carbs in every serving
they've got four flavors cocoa fruity
frosted
and blueberry it tastes amazing honestly
and legitimately
too good to be true they've got a
variety pack you can get all four of the
flavors all the flavors are equally good
but personally
i really like the blueberry i'm a
blueberry girl magic spoon is also keto
friendly
gluten free grain free soy free low carb
and gmo free i don't really i like
at this point it's hard it's really hard
to think of anything else to say
that would convince someone that they
should try magic spoon it's tasty
it's not extremely bad for you
there you go how many things are that
not many okay so go to magicspoon.com
roast to grab a variety pack and try
today and be sure to use our promo code
roast at checkout to get free shipping
and magic spoon is so confident in their
product it's back with a 100
happiness guarantee so if you don't like
it for any reason they'll refund your
money
no questions asked that's
magicspoon.comroast and use the code
roast for free shipping we thank magic
spoon for being a sponsor
of this podcast
they were banished to public schools
they literally like if you got pregnant
at bishop staying high school they were
they very discreetly sent you to new
bedford high school
we had i'm not kidding we had a daycare
in our school it was a class that you
could take
where you could like learn early
childhood like education but really it
was just like we had so many pregnant
girls at our school that would have
babies and continue to have to come to
school that they could send them to
daycare at school
that so first of all i actually think
that that's a brilliant
program i agree and i think to be in as
somebody who considers himself
very socialist leaning that's socialism
as if i could if i've ever named
something
i wonder how many schools have that
because i feel like i always heard tell
of like and also it's like this is like
it was always said in like a very racist
way but it's like
there's some schools where like they
have to have a daycare
it's funny i was on the opposite end of
that spectrum i think because i went to
like a poor school
in like a in like a a poor
area with lots of uh poor people um and
so there i was like
i heard tell of schools what they were
like oh they're schools that have
um like model um
right i did model um i did do model um
and you know what
it's as sexy as the teen dramas make it
i
would have i would have lost my
virginity way younger if there was model
you n at my school
all the boys got those little ties on
and i'm a talker so i
i seduced them all i guess my kind of un
my model u.n was drama club after i
after my
very severe uh cheerleading injury i
left
athletics in my past um deeply in the
past
and i joined drama club and it turns out
that's where i
that's where i belong what place did you
do
okay important segment like we should
make
just an official segment of the podcast
at this point because
people it's always me being like i was
glinda and wizard of oz now tell me all
the plays that you were in
wait you were glinda oh yeah okay okay
okay so wizard of oz was actually two
years before me
um and the lead was a black girl she
played dorothy and she went on to
be an american idol samantha johnson
she's great whoa
town hero we love her she's beautiful
she's talented she's amazing
that she's [ __ ] cool yeah she's great
i was
um violet beauregard in
in charlie in the chocolate factory i
got to wear um
a matching purple velvet jumpsuit with
this
other actress who played my mom it was
great i loved it
and i was in the front page of the paper
dressed as like a giant blueberry they
like made
this um giant plywood blueberry with
like a ladder on the back that i had to
like hop up and
put my little hands and paint my face
blue um and that's how they put me in
the newspaper and my mom still has it
cut out
why did you listen um i was
uh lucy van pelt and you're a good man
charlie brown
oh that was a part that i always wanted
and i always wanted our school to do it
and the only reason we did it was
because we were
we were planning on doing how to succeed
in business without really trying
and not enough men tried out so we had
to so we had to
we like switched last minute it was very
fun it is funny to like
even go there and be like no we're gonna
do that when like
i feel like every theater program is so
female heavy
we had a couple of guys but it was like
we actually had twin
twin brothers um and
we had this one guy who i dated patrick
for a while um
he left me for this other girl in drama
club and that's okay
they just got engaged they're still
together 11 years later can you believe
oh my god
the test of time yeah and you know what
if you
leave me and you end up with someone who
you get married to
good for you i'm so especially if you
marry your high school sweetheart
because you got yours really you know
sorry i mean how
emotionally distressed was teen taylor
as this situation was going down oh it
was the worst thing that's ever happened
to me
worst thing that ever happened to me um
and it was when we were still together i
was like you have a crush on camisha
don't you and he was like yeah and i was
like thank you for being honest
i was like trying to be a good
communicator i was like thank you for
being honest with me thank you for
saying that like we can work through
this and then he'd don't be like a week
later
um for her and i'm happy and it was was
it one of those ones
where like he dumps you and then it's
like
next day in school like he's he's got
her backpack
on or something he was trying to be i
think they were trying to be discreet
about it
but they were not being sweet about it
everyone in drama club loved this other
girl
so i could i didn't have the space to be
like sad about it
you know she was like such a sweetheart
everyone loved her so i i would have
been like that huge [ __ ] if i was like
mad about it but then high school
musical
oh my god high school musical and he
played the lead he played zac efron's
role
um troy bolton um and he could not hit
any of his high notes so that was my
um kind of revenge
i want to talk more about your
extracurricular journey because you're
saying you did cheerleading
you moved to drama but i think it's time
now to talk about how before all of this
you did have an acting career yeah um
on a television show that is beloved to
many
in my age group you were on zoom
i was on a show called zoom which was on
pbs
kids i originally actually filmed it in
the summer after seventh grade even
though i
absolutely look like i'm six years old
in that picture for some reason i was
you look like a baby yeah i was like a
full 13 year old
um i was holy 13.
i absolutely would have guessed seven
okay
i was i've always kind of just looked
young you know it's the type
it's the top skin it's just so dewy
after
i did zoom we actually i did a different
show for pbs called fetch with ruff
ruffman which was
a reality show for children um and it
was hosted by an animated dog
uh and i honestly
so when i was still in middle school
when zoom came out and so the idea that
i was on like tv was really cool to my
friends like my friends were all very
excited
um i made like the paper it was all very
fun and then the next summer i was like
oh okay so if i can shoot this other tv
show going into high school i'm gonna be
all set in high school everyone's gonna
want to be my friend i'm gonna be that
girl who was on tv
um it did not turn out that way at least
i'm gonna tell you
it did not turn out though
so while you're in middle school people
are like
yo you're on zoom that's [ __ ] up it
was i mean some of it some of my friends
were already like
smoking weed at that point so like they
were like sure
we support you because like where are
your friends or whatever but that
any assemblance of iota of support
that i had in middle school for being on
a children's show uh was completely out
the window by the time we were 14 and 15
and i was
still on a children's show yes my
friends were having sex at that point
and i was like yeah but i'm on a show
hosted by an animated dog
so um uh yeah okay
you guys spent last night getting drunk
i spent this morning
with rough roughness not to
brag but i do have to go to a promotion
and i do have to learn a choreographed
dance and it is
the target audience is four to six year
olds so
this is cool this is like really cool
yeah i thought it would make me so many
friends i thought it would make me so
popular and it did the exact opposite
so i i took it upon myself to get
popular and that's why i joined the
drama club
so was was cheerleading like a direct
you were like oh we need to pivot hard
my computer is not doing what i needed
it to do for me socially
like we're going full cheerleader it
probably was
um i in my head i did it because my
older cousin who was like my one of my
closest friends was on the squad and so
i was like i want to do whatever
morgan does um she's also in this
picture where she's
all the way to the right with the big
rosy cheeks and so she brought you
she brought you into the squad yeah so i
was like okay
this will be cool um
and it was i definitely got to like i
did i did
um football and basketball um
cheerleading so i got to go to all the
football games and like hang out with
all the cool kids that were like at the
football games but it was also
a nice way for me to not ever have to
reveal truly who i was
to the popular kids who were sitting in
the stands at football games because i
would like
a half time i'd run over like have some
chit chat eat uh you know eat some
french fries and then i'd have to get
back on the field
yeah so you didn't have time to reveal
like oh i'm actually a dork
you like exactly i'm actually working so
i was like yeah sorry i have to get back
to the squad
um did did being in the cheerleading
squad confer popularity upon you
um i think it more prevented
unpopularity from sinking into me which
is what i was looking for because i
could not have handled the pressures of
being popular in school
it wouldn't have uh it just didn't it
didn't fit with my
personality because i was frankly
incredibly weird
uh yeah this would be weird and popular
you know i guess in some school like if
you go to like a like a
performing arts school you can but i
didn't no
no no um and i know that you
like me were a pop punk emo
i wish i could have found oh actually
there's a pick in here where
i was um i was like almost in like
totally in my face
i'm wearing a green zebra uh
zebra print tank top that i got from hot
topic
oh gorgeous we'll we have to the tank
top yeah and like i'm wearing a purple
i was also wearing you can't see it
because i'm holding a chicken in this
picture for some reason
um a big silver chain that has
just a plastic bunch of bananas at the
bottom because you remember like 2006
where it was just like
uh we're random like we're so random
it was that like scene kid called
exactly where you're like i've got a
little like bow that's like kind of out
of my hair but also in my hair
like rawr means love and dinosaur
loved i still have a picture that's me
like going like and i like wrote rawr
so i was very on the scene in on the new
bedford
uh hardcore and pop punk scenes
which were pretty big at the time if
we're being honest like we got um
lots of regionally huge bands coming to
venues in
uh my hometown and i got in with the
uh pop punk and hardcore guys enough
because of my older brother thank you
very much shout out bryce darren
um that they let me work like the doors
like letting people in taking money and
they would always i'd get in for free
and they'd give me like a free t-shirt
like a free
like free merch and i was just once that
kind of era of high school started
happening that was like
late sophomore early junior year i
didn't care about being popular with
like
my high school like the high school kids
anymore because i was popular with like
dudes who are certainly creeping on my
15 year old ass that i did not realize
there's so much of that in like
especially if you're like a young girl
getting into
pop scene or whatever like you'll follow
a band around and then i remember on my
myspace i would like follow them
and then message that be like your music
rules
and then suddenly like actually the lead
singer damns me all the time and like
we're like so cool and interesting and
yeah
i look like i'm 12 years old and they're
into that
yeah yeah it's like i would literally be
like this guy like thinks that i'm so
like that my taste in music and my
thoughts on
music and like life are so interesting
and it's like no he's a pedophile
no it's like he's 22 and i just must be
like really mature for my age because he
wants to be around me all the time
and especially he's like trying to get
me to sneak out late so he must think
i'm like
extra grown you know what i mean yeah
exactly it's
he really wants me to try pot yeah
he told me that there's this pill i
could try i don't know i don't really
like taking pills i don't even take
ibuprofen but
it's like absolutely insane that i was
not abducted off of myspace oh 100
i should have been kidnapped 10 or 15
times over i think that we grew up grew
up in the time where it stopped being
like
um like before
like tinder and those kind of things
like people weren't meeting up like
romantically it was just myspace and
kids were like meeting up at the mall to
like
i don't know trade fans or whatever and
it was like totally fine and also our
parents didn't know enough about the
internet to be like
don't do this no what are you doing did
your
mind did you learn code to like update
your myspace
if i had just kept going on the path of
the html that i learned
i could be so rich right now there would
be no way i'd be on this podcast because
i'd be sitting in my penthouse apartment
in dumbo
as like a black female coder are you
kidding me i would have
i would have worked at facebook i don't
care i don't give a [ __ ] i wouldn't work
or sold my soul
i thought that so many times like i
learned
code in and i retained nothing
i retained nothing and i taught myself
are you
i taught myself i was like you know what
i'm going to put this
motion city soundtrack song on my
profile and it's going to start
automatically when anyone shows up and
i'm gonna hide
it with this code so that you can't turn
it off and you have to listen to let's
get [ __ ] up and die the whole
time you're at my myspace profile you
kidding me i was proud to ask if it was
let's get [ __ ] up and done oh
absolutely i had dead kennedy's kill the
poor
hell yeah that was my
song that played automatically on my
myspace and i
um my bio i'll i'll never forget it my
bio said
if you want to know me [ __ ] know me
[Laughter]
i okay this is not about high school but
motion city soundtrack was my absolute
favorite band and i love them so much
um before i discovered animal collective
and they took over my life in fact when
you said merryweather post civilian it
like triggered something deep inside
yeah
it's not their best album but it is an
excellent one anyway i love to commit
this to memory that was just like
to me there could be like the beatles
the james brown like there could be no
better
uh musician yes than the musicianship
that went into making commitments memory
by
motion city soundtrack so fast forward
to i graduated college and i moved to
brooklyn um my first job here in 2014
was
i um was working at this bar that also
did
food and my technical title was like um
oh x expo so basically like people would
order food on delivery apps i would make
sure that they got all the food in the
right bag and like utensils and [ __ ] and
then bag it up staple it give it to
the delivery guys to like take out one
of our delivery guys
uh was the keyboardist in motion city
soundtrack
and he obviously this was like in their
later years so they weren't touring as
much
but yeah and so he had a side gig when
he wasn't working that's fine i don't
judge
right um and i just was star struck i
like
asked him so many questions and he was
so nice to me and it was like the
coolest [ __ ] thing and it was like
i i just couldn't ask for anything
better until one night
um after the bar had closed we were all
having shift drinks and we were chilling
and we got
we all of us got into a conversation
about gentrification
so we had the chat um and it started
going in a direction to talk about race
obviously because they are inextricably
linked
um and he made the statement so taylor
um tell me answer me this question why
are black people no matter where they
are all over the world
um more inclined to commit violence and
less inclined to be educated
oh no and that's when i learned
not to meet my heroes it broke my heart
because it wasn't even like a casual
like accidentally racist comment that
like people make you know
this was like head measury like eugenics
level [ __ ] that like black people are
like inherently inferior and more stupid
and more violent and i was like
well and i will be committing that story
to memory
and i think everyone who heard it
oh my god this is a big one elise okay
this was my sweet 16. oh you did a sweet
16.
i played 16. um it was 80s themed
for what reason i have no idea i was not
born in the 80s no one in this picture
was born in the 80s
um but i went all out
uh that's a that's a pac-man board for a
cake i don't know
i rent there was a vintage shop in my
hometown that
called circa and they do actually like
period costumes for
movies and [ __ ] like lots of like lots
of costumes in films
but they have just like all these
decades and you can rent clothes from
there so i rent i rented like an
authentic 80s like kind of madonna look
dress
and had everyone else dress up like it
was the 80s and it was such a good time
everyone in the back like i see everyone
is dressed up yeah you've got an 80s
punk
on the side yeah different variations of
80s people
it was a beautiful place there's a miami
vice
type looking yeah mapachico that's my
dude
he's you know he i really feel like
everyone
dressed up this is cool yeah this was
maybe one of the last parties
that everyone went to before we started
all drinking and like
smoking you know it was like the last
wholesome like young
teen coming of age party um
it was so much fun did you have like a
boy that you were hoping to connect with
at it like what was the romantic image
in your mind of your sweet 16.
so i think i was too focused on myself
to um focus
on any point in that capacity um
but every it was cool because this was
like all of the different like
it was so the overachievers were all in
like one corner like the people i was in
the student advisory council with and
who like i got really good grades with
and then they were like kind of the um
people i went to middle school with who
were like
degenerates not the right word but we
were but they were like a little uh
like the troublemakers if you will and
then
middle
the drug dealer who i lost uh my
secretary position to was part of that
we'll call that um and then there were
um
the athletes and then there were the
drama club kids
and and show choir kids and everyone
came together
to eat cake with black frosting and
dance to
um madonna songs it was beautiful that
is
that is honestly very beautiful and
that's that's a really a wholesome
a wholesome gift it was beautiful
but i mean i'm like this could have been
a my super sweet 16 but
you didn't go to paris for the dress no
we spent maybe 200
on that party and a lot of it was from
the job that i had at coldstone creamery
oh my god okay wait so did you have to
sing
i sure did anytime somebody tipped us
someone could throw a nickel into the
tip jar and we had to
sing a song to them um also you got
bonuses if you came up with songs
um and also sometimes with people with
tip us and be like
i'm tipping you not to sing please don't
sing we don't want this
and i was like um damn i feel like cold
stone creamery was such an
institution at that time i mean
i'm sure there still are cold stone
creameries but
there was a period of time in my life
where cold stone creamery was a big part
of my
life oh absolutely this cold stone
creamery also happened to be
directly across the parking lot from the
ihop
and so i kind of flexed
my i work here privilege after drama
club shows like
because you know you end you end the
show and then you guys all kind of pile
into somebody's mom's minivan and you go
to ihop and you just
you just ruin all the employees and and
patrons at ihop's night
uh by singing songs that are kind of
like oh that were like in the play
earlier
uh and just being generally too loud and
not tipping enough because we didn't
have money
all of you were getting up on the table
yeah why were we dancing
in the ihop and those poor poor
waitresses i felt so bad for them
it was like like 40 of us splitting one
hash brown
you know because that's all we could
afford um but afterwards i would walk us
over to coldstone creamery and get us
the hookup
because i worked there wow the power of
that
it was powerful it was powerful honestly
i feel like
the team taylor that i am having
that is being created for me right now
is a
very powerful young woman she's like you
know what i have a television career
but it's not serving me socially i'm
gonna become a cheerleader
you know what i've been injured but i
and i will not allow my body to be
injured so now i'm i'm pivoting
i'm pivoting back to performance she's
having sweet 16.
there's there's a lot of power there you
know what now that you say all that i
feel
i feel more powerful now than i did 12
13 14 years ago and maybe that's all
what it was about yeah maybe it's about
looking back on your teenage self and
being like wow
were you a piece of [ __ ] yeah but like
you did it
you were your piece of [ __ ] you were
your
piece of [ __ ] i feel like that is such a
perfect place for
us to wrap things up so i am now going
to ask you our final question
can't wait um we asked this of every
guest but if
you were to speak to teen taylor today
what would you tell her wow
i mean we kind of just touched on it but
any other parting thoughts
i would tell her to realize that she's
hot way earlier
like skip the whole self-loathing thing
um because you did it for years
and you know it helped you it helped you
become funny you know and it helped you
like you gave you a personality and
that's great but realize you're hot
earlier
um because those ears are fleeting
yeah understand these these rock guys
want to [ __ ] you
exactly and did i no but i could have
realized i was just a little naive
also don't take that ecstasy pill senior
year because it's gonna [ __ ] up your
whole weekend
that those are great pieces of advice it
was mostly math if we're being
[Laughter]
taylor thanks so much for coming on the
pod elise thank you for having me on
this has been really really fun thank
you all right and for everyone listening
at home this has been the roast of your
teenage self podcast
you